welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford school of medicine today my
guest is Tony Hawk Tony Hawk is one of
the most celebrated and accomplished
professional skateboarders of all time
for more than 40 years he has been at
the Forefront of the sport and I don't
mean just doing a sport for more than 40
years I truly mean he has been at the
Forefront of skateboarding developing
new Maneuvers AKA tricks that include
incredible Feats like the 900 and 900
degree spin in the air as well as
numerous other Maneuvers that have
really pushed the entire sport forward
he's also completely popularized the
sport through his video game and through
his ambassadorship for skateboarding in
fact few if any names are synonymous
with skateboarding in the general public
as Tony Hawk and he is oh so deserved of
that title because for more than 40
years he has shown up as the consummate
professional he is kind he is respectful
and he is completely committed to his
craft and that shows up in every aspect
of his life he still to this day
skateboards daily and as you'll soon
learn he recently suffered a major
injury a complete break of his femur
that is the bone in his upper leg and
this is what many people would consider
a career-ending injury not only did Tony
come back from that injury but he went
back to the very trick on which he broke
his femur and recently completed that
trick that is a 540 or so-called mitt
twist I mentioned this because at every
level of his life Tony has demonstrated
himself to be somebody with Incredible
Drive incredible vision and incredible
persistence and today we talk about that
dry vision and persistence and we talk
about what it takes to set a goal and to
continually evolve one's goal and to
continually progress as a basically
young pre-teen as a teenager as a young
adult as an adult and well let's face it
as a 55 year old man he is now heading a
little bit past middle age although we
do hope that he lives forever
Tony Hawk AKA The Birdman really does
seem to be superhuman but as you learned
today he is oh so human in the way that
he shares his own experience and shares
with you the ways in which we can each
and all look at what we do and think
about what we want to achieve and put
our minds and our bodies to those goals
and Achieve them I confess that today's
discussion with Tony Hawk was a
particularly thrilling one for me to
have
I grew up in the sport of skateboarding
so I had met Tony previously although he
doesn't remember it that was many years
ago in fact I met his parents you'll
learn more about that story during
today's episode but I was aware of
course of Tony's accomplishments I was
also aware of his philanthropy so he has
a skatepark Foundation I also listened
to his podcast with another professional
skateboarder Jason Ellis called Hawk vs
wolf we provided a link to that podcast
in the show note captions as well but
never before have I had the opportunity
to sit down and talk to the Tony Hawk
and learn from him so I was absolutely
delighted to have this conversation and
it far exceeded my already lofty
expectations before we begin I'd like to
emphasize that this podcast is separate
from my teaching and research roles at
Stanford it is however part of my desire
and effort to bring zero cost to
Consumer information about science and
science related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme I'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast our first sponsor is element
element is an electrolyte drink that has
everything you need and nothing you
don't that means plenty of electrolytes
sodium magnesium and potassium but no
sugar the electrolytes and hydration are
absolutely key for mental health
physical health and performance even a
slight degree of dehydration can impair
our ability to think our energy levels
and our physical performance element
makes it very easy to achieve proper
hydration and it does so by including
the three electrolytes in the exact
ratios they need to be present I drink
element first thing in the morning when
I wake up I usually mix it with about 16
to 32 ounces of water if I'm exercising
I'll drink one while I'm exercising and
I tend to drink one after exercising as
well
many people are scared off by the idea
of ingesting sodium because obviously we
don't want to consume sodium in excess
however for people that have normal
blood pressure and especially for people
that are consuming very clean diets that
is consuming not so many processed foods
or highly processed foods oftentimes we
are not getting enough sodium magnesium
and potassium and we can suffer as a
consequence and with element simply by
mixing in water it tastes delicious it's
very easy to get that proper hydration
if you'd like to try element you can go
to drink element that's lmnt.com
huberman to claim a free element sample
pack with your purchase again that's
drink element lmnt.com huberman today's
episode is also brought To Us by Roca
Roca makes eyeglasses and sunglasses
that are the absolute highest quality
I've spent a lifetime working on the
biology of the visual system and I can
tell you that your visual system has to
contend with an enormous number of
challenges in order for you to be able
to see clearly Roca understands this and
has developed their eyeglasses and
sunglasses so that you always see with
perfect Clarity in addition they are
extremely lightweight and they won't
slip off your face if you get sweaty
indeed Roca eyeglasses and sunglasses
were initially designed for performance
in sports but now they include
Aesthetics and styles that are really
designed to be worn anytime I for
instance wear readers at night I'll
sometimes wear sunglasses during the day
when I drive and of course I do not wear
sunglasses when I do my morning sunlight
viewing which I highly recommend
everyone do their morning sunlight
viewing if you'd like to try Roca
eyeglasses or sunglasses you can go to
Roka that's roka.com and enter the code
huberman to save 20 off your first order
again that's Roca roka.com enter the
code huberman at checkout and now for my
discussion with Tony Hawk Tony Hawk
welcome thanks
I'm particularly thrilled to have this
conversation because
I've tracked your career for a very long
time grew up in the skateboard thing I I
know had your poster on my wall oh thank
you your name is synonymous with
skateboarding as you know I think a
question that probably get asked from
time to time but let's just clarify the
data from the outset Tony Hawk is your
real name right yes Anthony Frank Hawk
but I never went by Anthony I mean my
parents call me Tony since I could
remember so it's a fitting name given
the sport and what you do and we will
get into this a little bit later when we
talk about family and parenting and
parents
um but I'll allude to the story now that
uh
when I was 14 years old your parents
took me in yeah I slept in your bed in
your home so wild not with you in it but
surrounded by your a near infinite
number of trophies and and
um it must have been right after I moved
out
so this would be I was 14 years old
maybe I'll just tell the story now very
briefly I was 14 years old I was at a
contest at Linda Vista Boys Club
everyone left me and another kid named
Billy Waldman
uh we're still there your dad said
where where are you going
um it was clear that I didn't know where
I was going my life was I was a wayward
youth at that time and so they took me
in for uh a night maybe even two nights
your mom uh Nancy and your dad Frank
were so gracious brought me in into your
home took me to dinner
um I mean that tracks that would
definitely my dad and my mom together
would be doing that yes incredible
people
um and we'll get back to that story
later because you and I actually met uh
the next day in Fallbrook at your ramp
but so it had been 88 89 that's right
I'm gonna say I'm gonna say 89. okay and
it must have been one of the either NSA
or Castle contests yeah that your dad
was very active in well we'll get back
to that but uh I have so many questions
that relate to skateboarding to you and
really as a neuroscientist to the whole
concept of a life of continual
progression because
but they're not people listening to this
and watching this are skateboarders or
not and I imagine that most of them are
not
it's absolutely clear that you've been
in this game a very long time and that
you've somehow managed to continue to
progress over and over to come back from
very severe injuries and somehow keep
getting better and better so the first
question I have is about the younger
version of you um
did you have any sort of self-concept
like you know I want to be a pro athlete
or I want to be a skateboarder or I want
to have a video game named after me
right right exactly
um you know but if you can think back to
maybe even pre-skateboarding do you
remember what your self-concept was you
know this notion of like
um I have a self and I'm either similar
or different to other kids in some way
when I was young
I was put in a lot of advanced classes
and not that that felt like a badge of
honor it felt more like I was just
classified as a nerd
but then I thought okay well that's my
strength so I'll lean into that and I
thought that maybe I would be a teacher
because I thought well I I get all these
Concepts and I think I could relate them
to kids or to my peers because I helped
a lot of my classmates
through some of some classes so
that's all I really had I didn't know
and then when I would play sports I
would I would be okay you know I wasn't
I wasn't terrible but I wasn't the VIP
or the MVP and so I was just kind of
playing basketball playing uh baseball
um and then when I found skateboarding
I mean it was it was pretty obvious that
that was what I wanted to do it was once
once I got on a skateboard and realized
that I could maneuver it and do things
that were unique
and now they're moving the needle or
anyone cared but they were unique in the
sense of like I didn't I've never seen
anyone do this and this feels awesome
and so I just want to do this and so I
didn't think that this is my career I
was 10. so I just thought this is this
is my phone this is my hobby this is
this is my thing
um and I don't want to play these other
sports anymore
did you stop playing all the others yes
I I quit I quit little league in the
middle of the season when my dad had
been appointed president of that chapter
of Little League
because he was the coach he was always
very involved in all of his kids I have
three siblings so he was always very
supportive whatever they were doing and
then when I was playing baseball he
became a coach because he had time and
he was doing that he was he was you know
almost retired
um and then he was such a prominent
figure in the Little League they said oh
you're president now and so then someone
else was coach and then I was skating
and I was over it
did you immediately start skateboarding
in the parks on transition as we say or
were you pushing around in the driveway
like most kids it was I was
transportation
and skating was kind of a fad so I
started in 78 roughly maybe 77 even and
it was kind of a fad so
kids just had skateboards and they would
they would all cruise around you know
like it was the 70s so everyone had a
bike right and you knew wherever all the
kids were because the bikes were in the
front lawn and then at some point that
kind of turned into skating
so everyone had skateboards they're all
like
shitty
you know uh JCPenney or Big Box store
skateboards no one had really good ones
not in my area
um but then at some point we were just
looking at these magazines of people
skating and everyone's skating in pools
because that was the Dogtown and Z-Boys
era and it was like these guys are
flying I wanna like where do we do that
and then the skate park opened up in San
Diego that was Del Mar's Cooper uh okay
Oasis Oasis skatepark was the first one
in our area actually I take that back
Spring Valley was the first skate park I
tried to go there and I was nine and you
had to be 10.
and I remember like sitting in the
parking lot looking over the fence and
my dad didn't realize what they ate
because my dad would have easily lied
for me but he didn't realize there was
an age limit and he said how old is he
nine oh sorry he can't come
and then they closed
not long after so when I never got to
Spring Valley
um because I I think of you as
synonymous with Del Mar skate Ranch sure
well that was that came later because
Oasis skate park was opened up so this
was when I first went was like 78.
uh a friend of mine was going and he
said I want to go to the skate park so I
had to go get
you know this is such a hassle like I
had to go get the authorization form I
had to get it notarized by the bank for
my parents like to go there and then I
went and it was that was my Epiphany
when I first saw people flying around in
person I was like this is what I'm doing
for as long as I could possibly do it
because it looked it looked like magic
it really did it looked like they were
flying on magic carpets and and it spoke
to me in the sense of being a daredevil
but also
doing it individually not relying on my
team not
um getting
hassled by a coach it was just like oh I
can be part of the scene but do it my
own way and then uh
I skated Oasis as much as I could
whenever I get your rides there and
um then my parents moved to North County
San Diego when I was in high school
um mostly because they were just chasing
kind of real estate deals and uh and so
I got lucky that Dome our skate Ranch
was right there
every other Park closed but Del Mar
skate Ranch remained open so I mean
there was a bit of luck to all that and
it was based on geography
your dad's involvement is interesting
because
I got into skateboarding because you
know my dad wasn't around that much at
that time a lot of kids getting
skateboarding because it doesn't require
parent involvement was it unusual to
have parental involvement at that stage
yeah I mean I remember Frank and by the
way I remember Frank and Nancy your
parents with was with such fondness not
just because they took me in but I
remember thinking like there they were
at times the only point of stability in
a landscape of like 200 people where as
you know there could be potential chaos
of any kind and your dad had this way of
moving about like he wasn't afraid I
recall that he wasn't afraid to say what
he thought like hey don't do that like
impose some regulation at this contest
and at the same time it seemed me also
understood that this was a sport unlike
other sports like you're not gonna
regulate
kids like me at the time or you're not
going to try and control people so what
was it like to have your dad involved
and the reason I ask is that you're a
parent we'll talk more about parenting
but also it seems that he went from
saying okay you know little league other
sports which is more typical to okay
this kind of unusual sport skateboarding
but your mere interest in it was enough
to get him excited or motivated enough
to take you around to these places
um that's pretty special I mean that's
pretty it was I mean and in that respect
it was great to have his support and and
to rely on him for that the fact that he
was always around and he was in charge
of a lot of the events that that sucked
because
because it just marked me
um as one being favorited
um and spoiled
um and and most of my friends their
parents didn't want them skating so even
though they were stoked that my dad had
was was doing this kind of thing and
giving that kind of support they still
were like your Dad's here like this is
our thing this is our scene this is our
getaway from our parents
well I I didn't really have a choice in
the matter I did I did at some point
tell him my my concerns and my
frustrations with it but he didn't
really want to hear it you know he was
he was very much steadfast like well I'm
I'm been coming this far like you can we
can keep our distance at these events
but people are relying on me to organize
them and so I just had to suck it up for
a while did it push you harder like you
know if you could prove yourself with a
skateboarding that you didn't have to
worry about any claims of favoritism
because ultimately you can't fake you
can't fake Escape right right I mean
there's no deep fake version of
skateboarding you know you either can do
it or you can't do it and it's shown in
real time
so
um
and I suppose back then I recall you
were quite a bit
skinny or skinnier oh yeah I had I had
all kinds of things going against me at
the time yeah I mean I don't think
people will realize this unless they've
met you in person but nowadays there are
a few taller skateboarders out there
because the Sports grown so much
um but you're pretty tall you're like
six six three but okay I was not when I
was growing when I was that age I was
very small
um and kind of
concerningly small Because by the time I
got to be 16
I was still I looked like I was 13. I
used to get pulled over
I literally like I had a car that I
bought with my earnings I had a Honda
Civic 1977 cvcc and I would get pulled
over and then the cops would be like how
old are you again 16. like well you look
like you were 13 back there
um and then I shot up around age 17.
okay so that's interesting and we can
get back to this when we talk about your
almost remarkable levels of ability to
recover from physical injuries because
um well I'll just share a little bit of
a biological Theory here which is that
you know there are a lot of people that
study longevity and perhaps the fastest
rate of Aging that we ever undergo is
puberty right if you think about a kid
before puberty kid after abuse different
human being psychologically often
physically as well some people have a
longer Arc of puberty than others and
that does seem to correlate with a
longer life
and so it's kind of interesting you know
some kids hit puberty and they go
through all the markers of puberty in
like one summer right other kids it's
very very long and it sounds like we
don't have to talk about when you hit
puberty and the other markers but it
sounds like your growth spurt occurred
late oh yeah that's a terrific marker of
a long life by the way because what it
reflects is the onset of a big burst of
growth hormone out of the pituitary in
the brain and
if you continue to grow for a long
period of time that indicates you know
it gives you a little bit of the slope
of the line does that make sense oh yeah
so um this this may um have important
and fortunate consequences so at 17 you
shot up am I correct in Remembering uh
maybe you said it maybe somebody else
did that you were
um forgive me but so skinny when you
were a kid that you actually wore elbow
pads as knee pads yeah yeah that's a
true that's a true story for sure and
and
I took inspiration from others that that
I identified with namely Steve Caballero
because he was already an established
Pro when I started to come up in the
ranks or even get noticed at all and he
was wearing elbow pads on his knees in
this full-page picture of him and
Winchester doing a back sitter and I was
like that I want to do that and he's
small
and I feel like that's my goal yeah like
if he can do that I can do it it was
just more like oh this I identify with
that and and that gives me hope
um and as I recall Stevie also has a
pretty severe scoliosis right like at
one point Julius what he has at one
point he was turned turned pretty pretty
tight to the to the right or left I
don't recall which I mean still
incredible skateboarder loves TV he's a
NorCal guy so yeah I grew up I know
whatever he had is from birth but um but
it was more that his size and I didn't
even know he was he many not many but
you know he's like four years older than
me
um so I just was like oh there's small
guys doing that I can do it maybe but
when I got tall when I went through
puberty suddenly I had all these tricks
and then suddenly I had the strength and
the the height that gave me confidence
and so all of a sudden it was like oh I
can go way higher now
and I'm comfortable with these tricks
these intricate board Maneuvers and
stuff so that was a huge advantage to me
um the the smaller Stuff felt different
after that which was harder
um but being able to blast AFI in the
air as opposed to four feet in the air
was a huge Advantage yeah isn't that
wild when the nervous system knows how
to do something and then your body
changes and you can do the same thing
but with so much more Force even the
bowls look smaller
when I would stand on top I was like
wait this isn't that big
it's wild well the reason I ask about
this I think you know people listening
generally seem to assume that you know
if you become a Stanford Professor or
become a professional skateboarder or
you a professional soccer player that
that you were just fated to become that
right and it's clear that it's the
Confluence of so many different factors
um but one of the consistent factors for
sure is a sense that you just really
love doing it right I mean I can't
imagine getting
you know proficient or excellent at
anything without loving doing it right
and so still at this time when you were
let's say um 14 15
um did you have any concept of you know
whatever pro model I'm gonna none of
that well there was there was none of
that to be had
so we didn't have these great
aspirations because no one had really
done that before there were you could
have some success yes you could have
maybe a signature model but even the top
sales of skateboarding then wasn't a
career
the prize money was 150 for first place
100 for second 50 for third
couple tanks of gas some food yeah so
let's put it this way
I turned Pro when I was 14. by the time
I was
15 and a half and I had a learner's
permit and I could drive a scooter you
know I had 600 in my bank account and I
used that to buy a Honda Express uh
moped for a year and a half that was my
earnings
was six hundred dollars so clearly money
wasn't the uh the dopamine hit it was
the it was the actual skateboard sure
and that's what I mean though there
wasn't there was no goal of that because
it just didn't exist so I didn't care
like getting I I have my own vehicle
at age 15 like I was living large
I can get to the skate park on my own
that was amazing
to be 14
and be a professional at anything must
be
um a trip so to speak
um but what I'm wondering about because
I came up when
um your early cohort with Paul Peralta
so for those that don't know so-called
Bones Brigade right
I guess it was a total what like six
seven guys there were someone that were
a little more peripheral than others
um they're about six seven core guys
um in the various videos I mean you guys
were famous right you had posters
um on kids walls who skateboarded there
was a second or maybe it was a third
surge of popularity and skateboarding
um because it would sort of surge in
general popularity than disappear and
come back as it has over decades it
keeps coming and going
um to some extent
did you have a conscious awareness of
just how you know how much attention was
being placed on you know photos of you
videos of you and I'm just wondering
about the younger version of you whether
or not you know you realize what was
happening and the reason I ask is
because you've always seemed to me
somebody who through interviews through
videos through our interactions and for
those who have known you much longer
than I have
um just very grounded like not caught up
in it
um you know we've never seen headlines
about you kind of just you know blowing
all your money or you know wrecking cars
and you know destroying your life I mean
I'm sure you've made mistakes like any
of us but but you seem to have avoided a
lot of the pitfalls of quote unquote
famous people and celebrities and yet
you were a famous person from a very
young age
I
well I think it was that I didn't never
I never
that was never a goal and then when I
had a sense of it I was very
uncomfortable
I mean I was happy I was happy to be
successful I was happy that people
recognized me that that was amazing just
because I was good at skateboarding I
never imagined something like that
um and but I was always very
I mean some people thought that I was
sort of almost like pompous or arrogant
because I wasn't interacting because I
was just I was walled up I was like I
don't know what to do I don't know this
is the last words I would ever use to
describe you I think it was just more
that that that people would see me like
I go to a ramp I didn't know anybody and
I would just start skating and I'd do
all my stuff and they were like oh he
doesn't even talk to anyone
and I was like I don't know I don't know
what to do I don't know how to act also
you were 14 years old so Stacy broke me
out of that because I remember one time
there was a kid that was just staring at
me like hold my skateboard he had my
signature model and he said go say hi to
that guy
what are you sure like he wants he wants
to interact with you you know just go
high five of them or anything and and I
learned to sort of break out of my
comfort zone by doing that enough
um but my first go around I mean that
was that was sort of my first
uh wave of Fame I'd say the Bones
Brigade years
and we are so young that we thought this
is forever
and so we were definitely careless with
our our money with our actions and
um and at some point my dad saw that he
didn't think it was going to be long
term
because no one had had a long-term
career right so he he uh encouraged me
to to invest to get property like to buy
a house
that was the that was my Saving Grace
because I definitely was
spending on cars and things like that uh
yeah car like kind of a little bit
beyond my means I wasn't really
considering all my money was was 10.99
income so it wasn't we weren't paying
taxes on anything and at the end of the
year it would be like oh you owe this
much like wait what are you talking
about so
um for instance
hey do you want to go to Hawaii yeah
okay invite everyone
we're all going to Hawaii
I got well let's rent a place okay you
know and it was on me because I had the
means you mentioned Stacy we should
probably clarify for people
um Tony's referring to the great Stacy
Peralta yeah he was he was the one who
put me on the Bones Brigade when I was
still considered sort of a circus act
like a you know my my skating was not
really established
the stuff that I was doing was largely
made fun of because people thought that
what I was doing was just more like a
free show
can you explain more so my and let me
just tell you that my recollection first
recollection of you that I still have
that image in my mind would um is the
finger flip error right you know so for
folks that aren't familiar with
skateboarding you know people ride
around on transition or in the street
handrails stairs you know people
probably familiar with all those things
but um skateboards will Riot up toward
the top of the pool of the ramp and
they'll do something on the so-called
lip or the coping that's to ride at the
the edge of it or they'll go above it
like in the air but I recall seeing you
do the finger flip error I've never seen
anyone flip a board in the air I've seen
people do varial so right move it it's
going to be complicated for people just
listening but just flip it upside down
and then catch it in and finger flip
error yeah that was I remember that was
a jaw drop right it was like so if that
was considered circus era or circus uh
like then I don't know I don't know what
it was being compared to because at the
time we we probably watched that it was
in slow motion as I recall and we
probably watched it
three thousand times you know that
summer there's a big group of us that
all starts skateboarding that summer
um I would say kind of just before that
in that window is when people were
were more
um
giving me Flack for what I was doing
because I was mostly doing board
variation stuff but I still didn't have
the height the height in terms of the
height in terms of in terms of getting
in the air yeah so I was doing all this
stuff kind of right at coping level and
so people weren't taking it into
consideration or giving it much Merit
because it was just like oh he's doing a
little board twist or a bar turn and
then when I started to get some height
around the time you saw and started
doing those tricks like visibly way up
high that's when the the the shift
happened in terms of more acceptance
but I was still labeled as a as like a
trick skater robot skater and then you
had Christian osoy who was all Style
air is higher than anyone anytime he did
a trick it was going to be so flashy and
so amazing and Rockstar personality and
Rockstar personality and so
in that era you I mean it was very
divided it was like no one liked us both
you know what I mean
it was just so strange to be of that age
and of doing something that had never
really been established
and then suddenly I'm pitted against
another skater and we're just trying to
make our way through
15 years and and skateboarding and and
um it got it was it was hard I mean it
was like I got I got bullied
you know yes I was successful yes I was
you but but I would get I would get
uh Thrasher magazine would talk
about my performance when I would win
yeah I remember that because I was from
Northern California and Thrasher
magazine was a Skateboard Magazine from
Northern California actually wrote for
them for a while when I was a postdoc to
make some extra money uh under a
different name folks but you can try and
find those articles they're out there
um and then in Southern California it
was skateboarder mag Transworld mostly
Transworld skateboarding yeah it was a
trans World transport skateboarding and
Thrasher magazine were there were the
two the rivals right yeah um so yeah I
recall um some of those things that were
said
um it just is amazing to me um but it
brings about a really important lesson
which is you know that kid that gets
made fun of if they're determined and
they love what they're doing that's
going to be the kid that blows everyone
away later and I know this for sure
because I'll never forget there do you
remember the back to the city contest
that were called in San Francisco so I
went to those they were in the drain
fountains in front of City Hall I
remember getting there one day and there
was this guy with kind of like afro-like
hair pushing around he was doing what
are called daffies he had two
skateboards he was kind of like weaving
around and I remember thinking you know
San Francisco's other its issues now but
back then it was rough also for
different reasons I remember thinking
like this guy is going to get beat up I
hung out with the Embarcadero crew I was
like this guy's gonna get beat down yeah
that guy was Mark Gonzalez oh yeah so
one of the greatest
perhaps the greatest Street skateboarder
if you can't really Define these things
greatest and whatnot in skateboarding
um
but you know I remember thinking this
guy's just he's a kook and then I
realized who it was and then I realized
he was just like any other kid there at
some level and then a lot of the kids
that got teased early on they stuck with
it five years later I'm singing them in
the magazines and I think about this
with podcasting too there have been some
podcasters they've reached out early on
and had questions and you know look at
their stuff and you know one's initial
impression can be like what are they
like what are they doing here and then
you just see them two years later three
years later and they're doing amazingly
well and you're like this guy or gal is
here for good they're gonna they're
probably gonna be top of the game in a
few years so you never count anybody out
when you would go to sleep at night in
that era were you like laying on the
pillow going like oh my God people hate
me there's stuff in the magazines I
gotta push harder this is hard did you
talk to your dad about it I mean again
it's a lot to Bear even as an adult I
can only imagine what it's like to bear
as a 15 year old kid
I didn't really have a support group you
know or any resource to to
voice those concerns
um
I just knew I wanted to keep getting
better that was it and so if anything if
I was worried about those voices if I
was worried about the
whatever take people had on me
I knew I was going to go back to the
skate park and learn more tricks
um and at some point
I had so much of that as a foundation
that it was sort of undeniable that like
well he can do all this stuff and he
doesn't just do it at his home park
um and I think that's probably when the
tide turned for me is when when I
started to do well at other events
um namely Upland pipeline which was
for the most part the most frightening
pool that we could ride the thing was
big but I also recall like the the hips
as they're called like the transitions
the way they match up super tight
a lot of her giant coping super rough
like if you fell in Upland you're
getting shoot up it's pulling your knee
pads down but I didn't know that because
from the photos I wouldn't know that oh
it was it was treacherous it really was
like it was and and I wanted to do well
at the event and I would drive up there
every weekend like my friend uh Greg
Smith was a freestyler but he lived near
Upland and so I would go drive Friday
after school straight to Upland skate at
night skate Saturday all day skate
Sunday uh early and then drive home
um because I live in San Diego
and I just made it my mission to to
figure that thing out because
that was The Proving Ground for me
um Emma and so if I could skate that I
could go get anything
as many of you know I've been taking ag1
daily since 2012. so I'm delighted that
they're sponsoring the podcast ag1 is a
vitamin mineral probiotic drink that's
designed to meet all of your
foundational nutrition needs now of
course I try to get enough servings of
vitamins and minerals through whole food
sources that include vegetables and
fruits every day but oftentimes I simply
can't get enough servings but with ag1
I'm sure to get enough vitamins and
minerals and the probiotics that I need
and it also contains adaptogens to help
buffer stress simply put I always feel
better when I take ag1 I have more focus
and energy and I sleep better and it
also happens to taste great for all
these reasons whenever I'm asked if you
could take Just One supplement what
would it be I answer ag1 if you'd like
to try ag1 go to drinkag1.com huberman
to claim a special offer from now until
August 12 2023 ag1 is giving away 10
free travel packs plus a year supply of
vitamin D3 K2 again if you go to
drinkag1.com huberman you can claim the
special offer of 10 free travel packs
plus a year supply of vitamin D3 K2 so
it's clear you had an enormous Drive
let's talk a little bit about the
process of trying tricks and the English
anxiety associated with it did you did
you and do you have a sort of systematic
process was it you know I'm going to
learn the basics first like did you say
that do you say I'm okay I'm going to
learn how to do stuff you know at coping
level then I'm gonna do a little error
then I'm gonna go bigger I'm gonna do
this or um did you
just sort of um try what you wanted to
try and you obviously weren't haphazard
about it like how it seems you're pretty
systematic about exploring what's
possible and then pushing forward little
by little but um yeah maybe you could
talk a little bit about how you have
conceptualized okay tomorrow I want to
try this
um it comes in different forms but for
the most part I think about how I could
combine existing tricks
and would this trick work going into
this trick and could your body position
shift or would it all work in unison and
when I approach a new trick I'm saying
I'm saying more in the last 20 years
my thought process is I have all the
pieces to this I've done every bit of it
I've done that I've done the first part
of the trick in another form I've done
the second part or the grinding of it or
whatever
usually in some other basic way and then
the landing is well the landing is from
whatever that is and if you can throw
all those things together and make the
timing work it's gonna work and I I
never I never went at something with
some Hazard approach or throwing caution
to the wind like hope this see what
happens it's always very much like I
know I have all these things and so I
just have to put them together and I
mean now
things are so technical that my same
approach that I'm doing hundreds of
times one of them just works and it's
not because I didn't it's not because I
committed to that one it's because
of some tiny fractional adjustment that
happened that I didn't even know happen
and it just worked and I mean that kind
of is the curse of what tricks are now
because
there are plenty of moves that I've done
over the last 10 years even that I I
only did once because it was too
hard to get to and I didn't learn from
that one make
and that that is that's hard to accept
because in the past I was learning
tricks to have them in my Arsenal that I
could just throw them down at a
competition or a demo I've got that in
my pocket
these days like that trick for instance
I did a I did a 360 shove it five out of
fakie all right let's let's break that
down for real 360 shove it so who's
gonna take this on I'll let you take
this on I can try it from my knowledge
and perspective but whatever 360 shove
it is pushing the board with your feet
and letting it spin a full 360 rotation
under your feet in the landing back on
it it's it's a trick that people do on
usually on flat ground
I've learned I've learned to do it up on
the vert walls like I could do 360 shove
its kind of in the air
but I'm doing that I'm doing a 360 job
and then I'm landing on my truck
right like the axle Between the Wheels
on one axle in a what we call a 5-0
position which is basically a wheelie on
the truck so everything is so precise I
got to do 367 at exactly a certain spot
on the wall I've got to catch it so that
my truck lands when my foot hits it I
can't push it into the truck because
that that screws up my balance so it has
to land on the truck I have to land with
my weight perfectly
set back enough that I can come in
backwards because I'm doing this trick
and and I'm I'm gonna come in fakie
right 360 show 50 to coming in forward
is is a whole different Beast that that
I could probably do that just in a few
tries but the idea that I have to land
on this thing balance on it like a
teeter-totter and then reverse my energy
and come in fakie
backwards it's so hard it's so hard to
to get into the right position so like
any time I try it
there's like a one in ten chance I'm
even gonna get into the position I need
and that's the one I have to commit to
so every time I do it it's so intense
and it takes so much
so much commitment and so much
mind
I don't even know how to explain it like
the the
that you have shut everything else out
except this one moment and this one
fractional
piece that you have to make work
and it
I've done it once and I like I would
love to do it again but I know what it's
gonna it's gonna take the same amount of
effort I didn't learn from that one that
I made some trick that makes it happen
every time it's all so Technical and
there's so many things that can go wrong
that all is accepted okay I did it once
in thinking about the 360 show at 50
fakie uh
was that something that you thought of
the night before you decide that day do
you ever use visualization have you ever
had learning come to you in a dream or
find that you try try something went to
sleep that night next day made it
anything like that yes sometimes I'll
wake up the middle of night and I'll
write down something because it was like
oh there's this trick oh I think I could
do that yeah okay let me write it down
so you dream about skateboarding from
time to time yeah well yeah that shifted
a bit after I got hurt but yeah I used
to dream that I can't skate like I'm
trying and that it feels like the ramps
made of carpet I can't get the speed I
can't get the timing and then as I went
through this traumatic injury my dreams
shifted to wow I can skate I can do all
my tricks again oh interesting yeah a
little uh piece of science around the
can't uh can't skate piece or when
people feel like they're bolted down in
a dream or they can't run away yeah
there's this one phase of sleep called
rapid eye movement sleep where the brain
is very active the dreams associated
with it tend to be very Vivid and at the
same time we are completely paralyzed
and the idea is that no one really knows
why but that it's the case that we're
paralyzed to prevent us from acting out
our dreams it's also an interesting
neurochemical phenomenon because during
these rapid eye movement dreams they
tend to be very intense but the body
can't release adrenaline so it's almost
like its own form of trauma therapy it's
like you're experiencing this intense
thing in your mind but your body can't
react and so oftentimes people uh have
argued that that's why you feel like you
want to move and you can't because
actually can't yeah some people have
woken up while still a bit paralyzed and
REM have you ever had that happen we
wake up but actually a couple of my kids
have have struggled with that a couple
times yeah REM interference is called
it's not dangerous and usually people
can jolt themselves out but it's kind of
terrifying so that's interesting so
we'll get to a discussion about the the
recent injury and thankfully recovery
from the injury not miraculous because
that makes it seem as if it's surprising
frankly I'm not surprised that you've
recovered but it is um spectacular uh
the way you have but
you're saying that in your dreams before
the injury you would think about
skateboarding but you felt like there
was a kind of can't do it when I was
doing it in my dream there was always
some roadblock that I just cut like why
can't I get any speed why can't I why
can't I snap or do this trick um it's
more in the moments where it's Twilight
moments where I'm kind of awake and I'm
thinking about tricks that everything
else Falls away and I can actually focus
on
what kind of new moves to come up with
um
an example of that was uh
recently
I went to the X Games in Japan a few
weeks ago and
I was thinking I was going to go more to
show my support and because they had a
Verge event there's not a lot of bird
events anymore so if there's a vert
event it's kind of like if you build it
I will come because I want to show my
support that's that's kind of where my
heart is
and they had a best trick event and I
thought man maybe I could get in the
best trick is there anything new though
you know and I'm still recovering from
my leg and then at some point I was
falling asleep and I thought oh I could
do that trick and come in 180.
I know I could do that with with my
current state and not getting that much
speed so
to explain what I was doing is is a half
cab body rail to Backside blunt okay we
can walk through this half cab has come
up backwards come with 360. right so
half an hour ago as I approach the top
of the ramp I body rail that means I
jump around
and then I jump around on my board and
then I make sure that it lands with my
two trucks out and my tail on the coping
which is very precarious
and I've done that and come in fakey
beef that's the blunt piece that's the
blunt so I've done that right where you
and then you have to you have to use
your B to lift up the board come in
fakie right I've done that I've done
that twice
and I thought well I wonder if there's
something I could do like that and then
I realized that if I just keep coming
around and I come in
backside direction that keeps my body
spinning and that might actually be
easier
it wasn't but I figured it out
I think I saw a clip of this honest I
did it yeah I mean I did it I did it X
Games and I was like it was my last run
I was it was I mean it didn't move the
needle I got seven plays but for me it
was a huge moment it felt amazing I bet
oh yeah for sure I mean and it was I
mean it was like weeks of
preparation and trying to figure this
thing out I made it twice before the
event
um on my own alone on my ramp but um
that's just an example of of you know I
was I was literally falling asleep and
then all of a sudden I was like
half cup body well back to blunt
I love it that liminal State between
wakefulness and sleep is such a
beautiful state that if one is open to
ideas showing up there yeah they almost
always do I try to start trying it the
next morning
do you ever find that when you're taking
walks or in the shower or not thinking
about skateboarding yeah it's usually in
the in the sort of mundane moments that
that I get inspiration yeah do you have
practices for Pure relaxation aside from
socialization I know I was never
I think that's something I've been
lacking I I never was good at warming up
stretching
post-warm up
um
or or or relaxing you know meditation
nothing I just I I go skate and it's on
um
and as I've gotten older I realize
that's not the best technique but it's
worked so far it has worked
um so for you it's Go Hopefully a little
bit of warm up if you I have more of a
sort of OCD warm-up run
that I use to gauge how I'm feeling but
I kind of have to get through that like
a surgeon when a surgeon's about to do a
surgery
um they don't warm up they just check
off the various boxes of you know this
is here that's there make sure that
they're comfortable in their environment
and then they do they do the life-saving
work yeah yeah I'd say my warm-up run is
is kind of basic tricks but they give me
a sense of how how stiff or how I what I
need to adjust for it for the rest of
the day
so I guess it's not so OCD but it but I
definitely feel like I gotta go through
that routine
what feels the best like I I know that
making a new trick
feels incredible especially if you've
been at it a long time dialing it in so
that you can do it again and again is
its own form of reward yeah um but what
is the maybe list of two or three things
that just feels so good well that for
sure learning new tricks not even that
it's something that I created but just
doing something that I've never done
before
when I first learned varials backside
burials no one had done backside barrels
before they'd only done on the front
side
um and a variable is where you you reach
down grab your board jump in the air and
then turn at 180 under your feet it's
it's like a shove it but you're guiding
with your hand
I learned that halfway up the pool the
main pool in a way at oasis with no one
around and the feeling I got when I rode
away was something that I had never
experienced and then it is it is
literally the buzz that I've been
chasing ever since because it was like I
created something various below coping
was that was the button that was it it
really was and if you saw a video of it
you'd be like that thing like what can I
say it was it was the first time that I
thought
I thought of it
um I I went through all the Motions of
it I did the work and I figured it out
and you know no one no one cared but at
some point I was able to do it six feet
in the air and do a full 360 variable
and so that was the building block but
but that feeling was like no other
um I'd say that and then just even to to
strip everything else away like the most
basic tricks
like a backside Ollie is is an a
no-handed aerial that used to be what it
was called backside no handed Ariel
it feels so good because even to this
day people people say how does the boys
stay on your feet and I can't even tell
you how the board sits on my feet I just
know
I know how to maneuver it
and I know how to keep the pressure on
it and the friction going and backside
always is like
I think it's like a Marvel of physics
and and a clean back say to me it feels
good as anything yeah it's a beautiful
thing to behold I confess I've never
done a legitimate backside at all I ever
on a mini ramp sure but not on vert so I
can't relate to the feeling but I love
love love the fact that
you brought us back to that early
variable below coping feeling and that
that marks the essence of what feels so
good when you do something else right
it's sort of like a it's a as a
neuroscientist I see it as a chemical
stamp it's like a chemical fingerprint
of progress right
um
and I'm also delighted to hear that it
still feels that good to do these things
because I don't think anyone can have
the kind of lifelong progression that
you've had and it's still going uh
without a not just love of the thing but
love of the feeling that it brings when
no one's around because you said Skating
your ramp by yourself so how often are
you on your ramp with you know no one's
filming for Instagram no nothing for a
video nothing for a video game none of
that maybe there's you know maybe other
guys are around gals around we'll talk
about gals too because one of the big
shifts in skateboarding since I started
is that there's some amazing female
skateboarders now
um there's a young lady in fact that's
been skateboarding at your ramp forgive
me I can't remember her name is it Reese
Reese Nelson goodness goodness gracious
I know she is so yeah good so good so
good uh so we'll get back to that but I
think that you know people starting any
kind of sport or academic career or
business or anything I think people
assume that you go from zero to a
hundred somehow and that there are these
people that are just selected by
genetics or by Locker by some
combination of things to just like get
it and be better than everybody else but
it's clear that you've spent a lot of
time alone driving someplace to skate
the next day or alone at the ramp yeah
or um so do you ever reflect on that
kind of Drive
um and you know what what what that's
all about or is it just so intrinsic to
who you are innate I don't I don't think
about it I just know I have to do it
it's like
I mean I I we can get into it with my
injury but um
uh but but to go back to what you're
saying is you're saying that people
think that oh you were chosen for this
or genetics whatever have you saw your
last names
yeah when I first started skating there
was no way you'd think that I was
natural or that I had any future in it I
was all gangly I was all over the place
I was eating left and right like it
just it wasn't I wasn't good I wasn't
I wasn't a natural
um I've seen people that are Naturals
and I've seen that how they don't have
that drive they don't have the
discipline and
it's not wasted but
they just don't they don't utilize they
don't take advantage of what they have
naturally and and for whatever reason I
don't I don't fault anyone for it
um but I've seen both sides of it and
I've also seen other skaters who are
just driven and who are not really good
kind of sloppy and become the best
Andrew Reynolds
oh yeah when we put him on our team
he was just like me super gangling his
boards bouncing around but he's trying
every single trick and every time he
send me a video you know some new
technique that he's figured out and he
didn't really
by the untrained eye he didn't have the
skill set for
and then he became the boss
you know what I mean so I think it's
just you you have to you have to give
that as much weight as natural tone
if not more I'd say more yeah I would
certainly say more for Science and you
know that people were in the lab late at
night and early in the morning and
drilling away not not always the
smartest certainly not the um dumbest
but smart enough to show up when other
people are leaving and continue and I
think there has to be a little bit of
friction internally I mean you know
maybe maybe externally also but just
some friction some I'm gonna show you
yeah yes
okay my best example of that and I
haven't talked about this yet
um because I did it privately but
I I broke my leg doing a mixed with
something that I've done thousands of
times in my 40. 540. yeah so it's it's a
one and a half spin in the backside
Direction but that particular grab that
you do makes it a Twist because it makes
you kind of flip upside down so it's
kind of a one and a half somersault
I it's not my tricks Mike McGill's trick
I learned it not long after he created
it in 1984. been doing it ever since
I mean I'm talking about 40 Years of me
twist right I've gotten hurt once or
twice but not bad
anyway I around and found out
did one with no speed
last year thinking I could do it like I
was still 20 and got tangled up and
broke my femur
I had a super long recovery I had a
false start I had a non-union fracture
which means my bone never connected back
to itself and it kept pushing itself
further away
um and that's all uh in the past I've
got a second surgery in November and all
along in the back of my head is I got to
get back to 540s I have to
and I can't explain why I have to I hate
that it means that much to me
but it it's in here
you know I mean it's not it's not a
sense of Pride it's not like I have to
prove this to anyone I just have to do
it
and last week I did it
it was
so scary
and I prepped for it I
I mean even down to like my diet and I I
stopped drinking altogether and I was
like every time I go to the ramp I'm
just trying 540s like to get the spin to
get the to get the landing Zone with no
intention to make yet just that I had to
get there and then I had to have this
heart to heart with my wife that
you know she doesn't want to see me get
hurt she doesn't see me risking myself
at this age anymore she doesn't want to
live through another traumatic injury
with me
and
I had to tell her like I have to do this
she was gracious and accepting and
that's all I could ask for
it wasn't like she was like yeah you got
to go do it it was like okay
that's who you are
and so she was there she was my only
spectator
so good I confess I've seen a video of
this and my first response was
um f yes
and my second response was that was
really high like this is no you know
just above coping 540. this isn't even
you know this is a head high 540. I'm
not gonna make the same mistake I did
last time where I tried it low thinking
I just get away with it anymore so the
going high was more of a safety measure
which is ironic
the the bigger the ramps for me the
safer it is because I have a better
Landing Zoom I have more time in the air
to adjust
and even though it looks spectacular and
Music Experience it's just like no I
need that
I can't skate some eight foot pool I
have no Landing zone I'm Too Tall I'm
too I move too slowly now to do that
kind of stuff
so that's why you don't see me like in
the Park events and stuff like that you
know you're going to see me on this
14-foot boat ramp because that's my
happy place and that's where I'm safe
um but also having my wife there I just
knew I wasn't gonna get hurt in front of
her
because I would have been such trouble
the the emotional support and pressure
is uh is a real thing and in the best
ways uh not to focus on the bad aspects
of the injury because there are planning
yeah that I recall you and I
communicated not long after the let's
say let's call it what it was the first
break
and I remember you said to me over text
you said how long before I'm
skateboarding again and I said
um skateboarding as in pushing or
skateboarding as in
um what you do on vert you know and you
said uh what I do on vert and I said
well it seems you are doing a lot of
things you were doing deliberate cold
delivery heat pressure you do a number
of things I mean you're not haphazard
about your career and your body and your
health we'll get into that a little bit
later some of the things that you've
enjoyed as beneficial for you but
um you said I'm calling it at two months
and I said okay
um I believe it and then I recall that
you was it the Oscars or some other
award event where you came out about a
week later you came out there uh you
walked out this broken femur and you
weren't using any support to walk out so
you clearly ditched whatever support you
might have been using uh which I think
is Awesome by the way
um and then pretty soon I was seeing
videos of you dropping in I'm seeing
videos of you doing kick turns below
coping I'm seeing videos of you at
coping and you know we have a friend in
common the skateboard and generally
photographer Mike blaback and I remember
texting Mike I was like Tony's back
already this is this is superhuman rates
of healing and I think it is super human
rates of healing
then you mentioned that you
damaged broke broke the femur again so
did you allow more rest the second time
what was driving you to get back in it
so quickly the first go-around I just
didn't listen to any
of the professional advice because I
thought well I've done I've come this
far and I've always been able to push
through
broken pelvis broken elbow
um knee surgeries and I've always been
the timeline is always very shortened
for me because I just get back out there
and I and I get the healing started but
I also am comfortable with what people
think is extremely risky but
in this instance
I want to get back out there right away
and not long after the Academy Awards
uh I was actually walking with a cane at
that time and I ditched the cane just to
walk out on stage to present the award
so that was my big
my big coming out moment but it was kind
of forced and as soon as I walked out to
stay they grabbed my cane and I was
hobbling in the backstage
um but I was
I was skating kind of a mini ramp and
and I was already
struggling because I couldn't put my
weight on my front foot because my bones
still had not connected to itself so
there's a gap in the bone but there's a
there's a nail what they call a nail or
you know big piece of metal that's
holding them in place but I didn't
realize how careful I needed to be with
that because it was so precarious
and I decided I'm going to drop in on
the mini ram like I think I'm ready and
and it wasn't the drop in on the main
ramp it was me getting to the top of the
mini ramp and stepping off my board
that's always that kind of stuff but but
I just stepped off my board like I would
do any other day but I didn't think I
led with my front foot and I felt the
bone move in that moment
I I really I felt it I felt it either
twist or get out of place
and I was in total denial
for months
because I just said oh I just it just
hurts now like I you know I I got a
minor setback
and then I finally
eight months into my recovery seven
months into my recovery I was always in
pain my skating wasn't progressing I
couldn't get speed
and by all measures I should be back at
least I'd be back to a level that I feel
good about
and I went and got x-rays and they said
your bone never connected you have a
non-union fracture and and and and every
time I skated so my bones like this
every time I skated I was pushing it
further away
and so my bone was like this on the last
X-ray and and that was the hard truth so
for those listening just laterally
displaced think about a pipe that's
broken in the middle and just one's
offset to the other and and as I keep
skating and I I could force my skin like
I kind of learned this hack where I can
put 75 of my weight on my back foot and
25 of my front foot and do what I wanted
to do but it wasn't where I thought I'd
be
and it just hurt all the time I mean it
really was like that was my trigger
because I I have a pretty
high tolerance to pain and
it was always her like I I would dread
going to the airport knowing I had to
walk to a gate
so I knew something was wrong there I
went to a specialist
um that deals in non-union fractures and
he had a very pragmatic factual approach
and it was like oh I would do this I'm
taking that nail out and take the other
Hardware out and put it together and you
cannot move for two months
did you obey that at work I did really
yeah so what what is chilling I was not
going to risk that again did you um and
do you prioritize things like sleep
um nutrition
um just you know generally and did you
emphasize those things while you were
recovering from the injury yeah I I was
very disciplined in my diet in my
schedule and my sleep
um surprisingly I I was very busy
because
um I do speaking engagements and
suddenly my speaking engagements were
getting booked left and right
I mean to the point where I did a tour
through Europe Last Summer
of speaking engagement so that was that
was a silver lining I guess to my my
idle time
um and I leaned into it you know I made
myself available and
and uh it you know it's good money and
it was it's fun to to interact and
um but all through all through that of
course in the back of my head I was like
when when can I skate when can I skate
and then when I finally started skating
it was night and day with my leg I felt
like I could lean forward
suddenly I was learning tricks every
every session relearning tricks
um so I just I'm just lucky that I got
to live in this time of modern medicine
was that two months the longest you've
ever gone without skateboarding vert
yeah
yeah without skating at all
not even just pushing around
yeah good for you for obeying doctor's
orders and also finally and also good
for you for deciding that your rate of
recovery is going to be whatever it is
for you because I feel like I'm hearing
both things on the one hand you listen
to the medical professionals on the
other hand I'm not hearing oh you know I
looked at the average rate of recovery
from this kind of fracture this and that
it's it's like it's as if you decided
two things at once that there are
experts who have something to offer me
here I'll follow their advice and yet
I'm the expert at myself here I'm
putting myself in your first person uh
Tony's the expert in Tony and
I'm going to make sure that I come back
100 yeah or better
yeah not better but um and I've and I
have come to terms with that
because I know that I'm not going to be
pushing myself the way that I did before
I got hurt anymore
there are some tricks now that are way
more difficult just because whatever
something changed in my body and for
instance I can't grab slob like I can't
I I can't do it consistently that used
to be my go-to grab you could do that
anytime over 60 foot gaps whatever like
I could I just grab I knew where my
board was I knew that was going to hold
on to my feet and half the time I try to
grab that way now I don't reach it or I
grab my foot instead and I I don't know
I can't make the adjustment to fix it
and so I've just sort of come to terms
with well that's not the go-to grab
anymore
and that's okay I had a good run yeah
your kid's pretty pretty uh vast so
there's a lot of other things to reach
too aside from the 540 which by the way
congratulations not only is it a 540 but
uh done at least head high I've seen it
with my own eyes and um and under really
great circumstances your wife there just
the two of you and after and the trick
that broke the femur in the first place
yeah so um congratulations on that thank
you I'd like to take a quick break and
acknowledge our sponsor inside tracker
inside tracker is a personalized
nutrition platform that analyzes data
from your blood and DNA to help you
better understand your body and help you
meet your health goals I'm a big
believer in getting regular blood work
done for the simple reason that many of
the factors that impact your immediate
and long-term Health can only be
analyzed from a quality blood test
however with a lot of blood tests out
there you get information back about
blood lipids about hormones and so on
but you don't know what to do with that
information with inside tracker they
have a personalized platform that makes
it very easy to understand your data
that is to understand what those lipids
what those hormone levels etc mean and
behavioral supplement nutrition and
other protocols to adjust those numbers
to bring them into the ranges that are
ideal for your immediate and long-term
Health inside tracker's ultimate plan
now includes measures of both apob and
of insulin which are key indicators of
cardiovascular health and energy
regulation if you'd like to try inside
tracker you can visit insidetracker.com
huberman to get 20 off any of inside
tracker's plans again that's inside
tracker.com huberman to get 20 off are
there other things that you you're
thinking you know can't wait to get back
to that let's set aside slaw bears for
now yeah
um
yeah I I want to get my hand plants back
the way I used to do them yeah I have
yet yeah it's so invert like it's
one-handed handstand
um I can do them now but I've seen you
do them recently yeah but but I used
they used to be my signature it was a
tucking Amber and flopped all the way
back and and I can't get a hold of my
board to pull it all the way back like I
used to
um if I can get that I'll feel like
that's it that's that's that was the
last Milestone I'm not here to uh
diagnose and treat these uh specific uh
skateboard trick isms but between your
what you said about the slob air and
what you're saying about this seems like
they're same thing about about getting
your your your front hand around and
around pulling it back back in uh behind
you so maybe this is like the way that
the femur is lining up with your pelvis
and maybe some off-ramp something or
other Physical Therapy could do I'm
actually working with um at best core he
is a he is a doctor of physical therapy
and he has helped me immensely through
my recovery and when I'm frustrated with
this motion or that's the same grab
actually as in the twist
he worked on me before it and was just
contorting my body and my leg into these
positions that
I don't really even get to when I'm
skating just to prepare me for that and
he did but that's what it took
it's interesting that we're talking
about skateboarding and we're also
talking about physical therapists we're
talking about nutrition we're talking
about sleep so growing up means like
none of that none of that never imagined
any of this and I'm chuckling because
you know growing up in skateboarding
um early on for me uh not quite as early
as you but pretty early 12
um and got out of it and back and yes I
can still do a thing or two uh here and
there um but that's not the point the
point is that you know the nutrition
consisted largely of you know fast food
or whatever was around
cigarettes and beer were sort of the the
energy drinks and uh uh and um
supplements of of the times this is
fortunately changed but there there was
essentially no
Health promoting tools or aspects to it
at all but that was back then but then
over time it seems It's evolved like now
I see um I saw a couple posts from
Stevie Williams like he's in the gym
sure um I think I saw Danny Way early on
working with Paul check and doing some
balance work neck work because he had
broken his neck surfing and things of
that sort so there seems to have been a
big shift over the last 15 20 years
where skateboarders are taking good care
of their bodies like other athletes
thinking about the resilience of their
bodies and also generally taking better
care like a lot of them opt not to drink
and do drugs and all those sorts of
things so I mean how does it strike you
to see the way that skateboarding has
evolved towards the option to be much
healthier and treat it like a like a
serious sport where you're a serious
athlete a word that you know even 15
years ago 20 years ago if you called a
skip order an athlete some people might
even be offended by oh yeah people in
skateboarding right absolutely yeah
um
well to answer your question in the
early days
that was part of the the scene and the
culture just because the the it was the
antithesis to organize team sports
and mainstream culture and so it was
just like yeah this is what we do
it who cares like we drank and we skate
and everyone it was it was Wild West
right
but as I never fell into that deeply
because I saw how it affected people's
performances and the skating itself was
Paramount to me that is what I want to
focus on that's what I want to be good
at and I saw people partying and
partying their skills away so I had at
least that forethought
um and then as scanning got more
established popular
more of a career option than people
started taking it more seriously
especially competitors I mean and and
but there's such a wide swath of of what
skateboarding is and it's a big tent so
to say that it's more organized yes it's
more organized over here there's still
all these skaters over here partying
hopping fences
don't care about contests don't want
sponsors oh like GX 1000 like those kids
at bomb Hills in San Francisco like like
but that that's what I love about it is
the diversity of it all and that that's
we're all part of this scene so
I I was a competitor that was that was
my path to success and so I appreciate
that people take it more seriously now
and that they do have trainer they have
resources I mean they have sponsors that
will pay for this kind of stuff
there was no such thing I mean like at
our biggest skate contest we were all
staying at Stacy Peralta's parents house
the night before and he would take us
out to get spaghetti because he thought
carbohydrates was going to give us
energy the next day that was the extent
of training in 1983.
right but nowadays it we're treated like
High Elite athletes because they are
like if you really look at people that
are at the top of their field people
like Niger Houston
you know what I mean like the dude is a
machine he is
he is one of the most precise skaters
that we've ever seen or precise athletes
this side of Nadia coming each
you know yes I'm I'm I'm aging myself
but
what I'm saying is like this is this is
takes hardcore dedication Precision
athleticism and
devotion and so now they have the
resources to back that up and to keep it
going longer I mean yeah would I be able
to do this now especially after getting
hurt without the help of a doctor of
physical training
probably not
I'd do it on some level but I wouldn't
get to where I am now
um and so hey I think it's awesome I you
know I I never I never wanted to covet
skateboarding as this thing that no one
else could like a gatekeeper to it no
one else can touch it I always thought
there was something to skateboarding
that was magical and that was good for
mental health and that was
that was required such
um
required such passion
and I didn't I never understood why I
didn't get bigger through those those
leaning years it was always like kids
this speaks to kids like it's Daredevil
and it's active and it's exciting and
you can do it as a group but you can do
it your own way and I don't know all
those things it took a long time for
everyone else to figure it out they
definitely figured it out I mean
nowadays skaters are the cool kids in
school yeah it's in the Olympics like
there was always discussion would it be
it was an exhibition sport in the
Olympics at one point no uh no no oh I
thought it was it for maybe it had a run
it potentially being an exhibition there
were there was talk about it got it um
but it never did and and not that I mean
at some point especially in the late 90s
or 2000s
skating
was getting appreciated and and kind of
reached that threshold of of is it
mainstream well it's in it's all
McDonald's commercials so I guess that's
pretty mainstream and so we already had
come of age and it was like we don't
need the Olympics
we're already more popular than
a lot of Olympic sports right so why do
we need their validation and then at
some point it became like the the power
Dynamic shifted and it was like oh they
need our cool Factor
we don't need their validation
and I was like yeah okay you guys want
it sure
go ahead but hold the events hold the
qualifiers
we'll participate
but
we don't need this
well you've been an amazing Ambassador
for the sport that's driven so much of
that wider acceptance and progression
and invitation into different domains
one of the um things that I definitely
want to talk about is the video game
right because I think that the video
game changed a lot of things for the
general public in terms of their
perception of skateboarding I mean what
it allowed of course is this is obvious
but it allowed kids that weren't going
to you know um bang up their shins or
walk in with a broken wrist or you know
all skinned up too to do incredible
tricks but in silico on a screen right
and to
and pretend that they are the the pro
skateboarder that's essentially what
what video games are about And yet when
you can see something just like you can
imagine it in a dream or while you're
falling asleep and you can see something
and and hear an air quotes do something
in a video game it also is going to
inspire a number of kids to go outside
and grab a real skateboard and try that
or try something like that so clearly
the video game was a catalyst for what I
consider now the the wide acceptance of
skateboarding as a sport in all its
various forms
um could you just talk for a little bit
about the Genesis of the video game were
you into video games prior to the video
game
um were you into technology generally
and and what sort of motivated the
interest in the video game because it
certainly has changed the face of actual
skateboarding and the perception of
skateboarding
um well I've been into video games since
the gecko I mean I was a kid you know
playing pong Pac-Man Missile Command
Qbert you name it and then getting the
home systems in television Super NES
Commodore 64.
um
Sega yeah but but I um and I always love
technology so when I when I finally
started making money in the 80s my first
kind of big purchase in terms of that
uh in in terms of electronics was uh
Commodore Amiga
which was considered one of the highest
end uh home computers you know alongside
Mac but but more graphic oriented and
and more game-oriented
um and so I was always into that idea
that you could do this kind of stuff at
home not just in arcades
and then I gotta I got a call from a PC
programmer that wanted to pitch a skate
game and had a crude engine of um a
skater that would cruise around go in
bowls and stuff like that and it was all
keyboard controlled it was clunky but it
was something and the last thing that we
had as skating was
720 in the arcade or a skate or die for
home systems for Commodore 64. that was
like the last thing that had happened
for skateboarding
um in video games and so I went with him
I was excited to get like I got to
we got to go to Nintendo and Pitch it
um we went to Midway you know we went to
all these different uh console and
software manufacturers
and were just told that this is a bad
idea skateboarding is not popular
home video games are barely a thing why
would anyone want to buy a video game
about skateboarding
someone said those exact words to me
um at Midway
and so he got frustrated and he needed
to find a job and I was I was just kind
of free-floating so I said okay he goes
well I'm gonna I'm not going to do this
but I feel like you've established
yourself at least in the Video Game
World uh industry that you're interested
in doing something so maybe if someone
does something they'll call you and I
was like yeah right sure sure enough
like a year later Activision called me
and they said hey we heard you want to
do a video game I said well yes I would
love to work on a video game I'm not a
programmer or anything so we have
something we're working on and we'd like
to show it to you and so I went up to
Activision
um they were working on a skate game but
it was based on an engine of a game that
was already released called apocalypse
starring Bruce Willis so the first
version of my game was Bruce Willis on a
skateboard
with a gun shot to his back
in a desert Wasteland doing kickflips
and it was awesome it was it was truly
like I picked it up and I got past that
Visual and then I started playing it and
and it was intuitive it the motion felt
right the engine was right and I was
like this is
this is the Baseline of something
special
I didn't think it was going to be some
big hit I just thought this is this is
going to be appreciated by skateboarders
and that was my goal the entire uh
development process which was about a
year and a half after I signed on we
through that year and a half we were
going back and forth with they would
they would FedEx me builds on CDs I had
a modified PlayStation and I would play
it make notes and I thought man skater
was going to dig this and that was it
and skating wasn't even that popular it
was coming to you know it was starting
to get some traction what year was this
again like 98 so it was like X Games
were starting to come into the fold
people were taking note of what
skateboarding had become at that point
and then I thought this is going to be
cool skater's gonna like it and then
um
not long before the release
they called me and they said hey we want
to um we want to offer you a buyout of
future royalties for this game
um because I think you know there's I
think people are going to like it I was
like what does that mean they go we'll
give you a half a million dollars and
then you don't get royalties going
forward but you get that money up front
and
at that time my life like to hear
someone say half a million dollars
seriously sounded like a half a billion
dollars
like no one had ever
talked about numbers that big to me well
also 98 was a little bit of a of a quiet
time for verts skateboarding too right
sure yeah but yeah for yeah
luckily vert skating
still was a thing because of inline
skating
because inline skating was huge right
late 90s and they were all vert and so
we as skaters got to sort of ride those
coattails because it was like Hey There
are boat ramps because everyone's
rollerblading I forgot about that that
did like and I have honestly like I was
the special guest at a couple of inline
rollerblade shows where it was like this
is what team rollerblade live and
special guest Tony Hawk the skateboarder
and I was like hey all right dropping in
but it paid the bills yeah
um so to answer to like to to
perform what you're saying bird skating
was
it was a thing at least established in
the X Games
which was something and enough for us to
make a living
um so when they offer me this money
I actually was in a pretty good place
um in terms of
my I don't know my options my my
trajectory and I felt like and I I had
just bought a new home and I thought I'm
gonna take a chance and to see what
happens
and like that was the best financial
decision I ever met took the equity
yeah I just let it ride I was like no I
want to see what happens with this and
as soon as the game was released it was
getting
Stellar reviews and then I remember like
the very next week after it was released
never stopped saying okay we're working
on number two what do you want to do
like what do you mean
well yeah we're doing SQL which what
awesome and then we ended up doing like
10.
amazing crazy amazing
I'm thinking about your decision to not
take the cash and to see how it would go
I'm thinking about your decision to buy
a car at 16 and yet as a consequence get
pulled over because you look younger
um I'm thinking about the time when
through the graciousness of your parents
who took me in because I had no money to
get back up to Northern California and
they couldn't get a hold of my mom
um they took me to your home but then
they took me to where you were living
the next day which was in Fallbrook you
don't remember this but I do and I know
you've heard this story before so
forgive me because most people listening
haven't but I remember getting driven up
to Fallbrook you had the ramps in your
backyard
I walked in got introduced to you you
were very gracious said hello what's up
I said feel free to push around on the
ramps outside it was the mini it was a
spine ramp yeah
um two ramps back to back folks it's
fine uh sorry nomenclature
um I think Ray Underhill was there
yeah he lived there for a while yeah and
as I recall you had
um pretty vast music collection and
we'll talk about music
um but it also seemed there was a couple
cars in the driveway and whatnot but
it's clear to me based on a number of
things and that interaction and what I
observed there that either you had
someone in your ear either your dad or
your mom or both or maybe it had been
Stacy or maybe it was somebody else who
was advising you to make very good
financial decisions like not spend all
your money or continue to spend all your
money
um to invest in things you know or maybe
it was just instilled in you at a young
age who knows
I'm asking because I think so many
people burn their early success you know
what represents a lot of wealth for them
early on they burn that where they start
making just bad decisions you explained
before why you tended to avoid drugs and
alcohol and certainly um any severe
relationship to drugs or alcohol that
would keep you from progressing and
skateboarding but you know the ability
to make really good decisions as a young
famous athlete
is more rare than it is common
even when people have coaches so I'm
curious you know where did that um
shrewdness and that Prudence come from
and was Frank your dad and maybe Nancy
also you know advising you all along
like hey you know
um think smart be smart because clearly
you've made some some very smart
decisions um he was definitely
a guide in it he he was the first one
who said you should probably
buy real estate I was 17 so I didn't
even know that was possible but he
co-signed made it possible
um but then after that I ended up buying
that home that you went to and it was
four acre property and we built these
ramps on it and that was amazing and
definitely helped Propel my skating to a
different level than I ever imagined but
at some point that was just a drain and
it was a drain financially and I was
living beyond my means and my income
kept dropping because we're talking
about not long after that was 91 92 the
slowest days of skating and I've got
this giant mortgage
and I've got this property and these
ramps that I can't afford to upkeep I
can barely afford my water bill at one
point you know and so
what you saw might have seemed stable
but behind the scenes it was it was
starting to unravel birdhouse hadn't
been started birdhouse was started in 92
and when I started birdhouse I took the
equity from that house to start it
because I didn't I burned through my
savings from trying to keep this place
going
um so I took a second mortgage out on
that house right I took my Equity out
started birdhouse sold the house for
what I had taken out and then moved to
my original place that I had when I was
in high school and just
pulled back on expenses I think that was
that was when I really became shrewd
because I had to I had I had a first
child
I had an income that was very uncertain
very fluctuating and I was just eating
Taco Bell and Top Ramen and peanut
butter jelly sandwiches and and
not spending anything and and taking
every job
like the most random demo requests or we
want you to be a consultant on this
commercial because I'm too old I'm 24.
I'm too old to be the guy skating
because it has to be youth right but
they're like well we want to see what's
possible so can you come up the day
before and show us the ropes and so I
would be the stunt skater
that's filling in to show them the
Angles and stuff and then they would go
higher Chet Thomas
as the young kid
and then I would stand around I was
getting paid I didn't care I think I
remember those commercials It Was a
Serial commercial something like that uh
the serial commercial was uh Chris
Miller Frosted Flakes right and I was
Tony the Tiger
guys you chat uh yes
um I throughout the birdhouse which is
your company but without telling people
what is a skateboard company I remember
uh Willie Santos was early on I remember
his super nice kid I used to see him at
the contest I remember thinking well
Tony Hawk has his own company for
skateboarders we had a team you know
like willy willy was a maestro
um Jeremy Klein legendary Street Pioneer
uh Steve Berra who's kind of a we called
it ATV but Street and vert
um we had uh ocean Howell it was like
our number one amateur we had Andrew
Reynolds Matt Beach
um we had a team it was full on was it
fun to move from Ryder to also Ryder but
team manager owner was it fun it just it
was just necessary
I can't say it was fun I mean yeah it
was it was fun because we were still
just
kind of Reckless and
driving you know six of us in a van
driving to skate shops across the
country and
begging them for 300 bucks so that we
could get gas and food in the hotel room
and
get on our way
um
I don't know it just it but for me it
just felt like a necessity to keep to to
that was what I had to do to make a
brand happen
and so I was willing to do it
um and but
it was exhausting
yeah because I had to be the
had to be the the coach
and the tour manager
and the skater
you know I was putting myself out there
on like the worst conditions
and just rolling my ankle left and right
and it was and it was all Street and it
was just wasn't my thing it was it was
hard but I just I loved it it made it
happen in my mind I'm thinking you had
to be Tony Hawk the skateboarder Frank
Hawk the organizer yeah and Stacy
Peralta the yeah because Stacy had been
a pro skateboarder I still think of him
as a skateboarder yeah even though he's
filmmaker right skateboard just like I
still think of Spike Jones's
skateboarder bmxer filmmaker
um seems like you had to integrate all
of those
and I mentioned that because
I am curious I think a lot of people are
probably curious like are you the type
of person like sit back in a chair at
night and think like okay like how I'm
gonna do this I mean are you
contemplative or is it really you just
identify what needs to be done this year
and over the next three years and you
know set your Milestones kind of short
in I guess so now we're back then back
then
oh no everything was just in the moment
we got to get here
we got to get to Dallas by tomorrow
like as soon as this Demo's over getting
the van we're going
um we gotta get a hotel room
you know it was just stuff like that it
was it was very much but but I I
respected I think I learned to respect
um
punctuality
because I travel with playing at skaters
that were not and didn't care and show
up late and was like dude and like I
don't know these guys and then when I
was in charge it was like we're going to
be on time because we have to respect
other people's time
and we said we're going to be here at
three o'clock we're going to be there
three o'clock
um and
that's not easy with a skate crew
Mike blaback who as you know is it's a
girl to the Hebrew and Lab podcast I
talk about that we've got some other
um guys that came over from DC to as
filmers and editors for us and you know
they're so punctual and they're so on it
and I notice you showed up early today
right right on timer early
um early by five minutes
um and that is a distinguishing factor I
think in any occupation but especially
in skateboarding where there's this kind
of looseness sure and so if you do show
up on time it really means a lot
um the professionalism that you know was
instilled in you it's it's clear that
different places where that's showing up
mentioned the shrewdness about the
business decisions I'm curious about
another aspect of that which is maybe a
little more cryptic which is you know
whether or not it was the CD collection
that I saw or your mentioned of the car
you're just in video games it seems that
one thing that you've done that a lot of
guys that I knew because back then by
the way it was mostly guys now so we
said they're women doing it too
um women and girls
it seems like you have a lot of other
hobbies and interests music and Etc but
that we never heard about you getting
like distracted or pulled down those
lines like we didn't hear about you
going and surfing and getting hurt hurt
surfing so that you couldn't skate we're
getting really into motorcycles or race
racing cars right you know um some
people went hard left out of
skateboarding into that like Ken Block
the late great Ken Block but that became
his main thing seems like you you knew
that skateboarding was the main frame
and stayed with that
um and yet you have a lot of other
interests yeah I think I I well
with other sports especially
like Motocross I I have this huge
respect for Motocross I think it's super
exciting I would love to do it and I
know that I would not Escape unscathed
like I would definitely want to learn
the tricks
do whips and flips and whatever and I'm
gonna get hurt and I I don't want to
risk my skate career for that so I I
purposely pulled away from that type of
thing
um the last knee surgery I had is
because I overshot a jump in Mammoth on
my snowboard so that was a lesson I was
like don't what are you doing just
Cruise why yeah stay on the ground right
hit the powder right you know free ride
with your Bros because I learned my
lesson and so so yeah you're right but
at the same time like I still I still
love going surfing and snowboarding I
don't do them as much obviously
um but but those are part of of what I
did all growing up
um and they're important to me
um I did you know do a couple of
celebrity car races like a NASCAR race
and
um I totaled a car in the Long Beach
Grand Prix
because this dude ramming to the wall
and it was like well that was fun but
I'm not
I don't I don't have the bandwidth to
get that serious about it and now you
have a family of course too so of course
yeah I mean and and those things as fun
as they are and as as
I don't know
um
as sort of auxiliary as as they are they
require a lot of time
I mean just for instance that Long Beach
Grand Prix they want you to go stay in
Palmdale for like a week and a half and
train
and and figure out how to truly know how
to drive and be safe and it's like I
don't know I ain't got time for that
yeah that's time you're not
skateboarding or with your family right
yeah right now I feel the same way if I
get pulled away from Reading papers and
prepping podcasts and
reading the latest research and thinking
about experiments we could do then I for
more than a couple of days I started
feeling the itch I have a feeling this
stuff is programmed into one's nervous
system after a while like you've been
skateboarding for so long that if you go
a few days
it probably just your system is is
water or something oh yeah for sure I
mean
um well just for instance uh our ramp is
uh being torn down on Sunday today is
Friday our Ram is being turned on on
Sunday at 10 A.M to be moved to Salt
Lake City for our big bird event
I'm going there at 8 30.
so I can get a session before I can
start down I love it on Father's Day
that's my father's day I'm going to work
at 8 30 a.m on Sunday I love it
speaking of family and lineage uh tell
us about your kids you've got some
talented skateboarders in your family
besides yourself I do um well I have
four of my own and I have two step kids
and um they all skate my daughter not so
much anymore but all the boys five boys
uh are all really into it
um my oldest son is the most uh
he's the most prominent because he
turned Pro
um and has I mean
you know has his own following has a
name for himself uh Riley and he's 30.
yeah he kills it on Street he's a big
street skateboarder he does yeah um but
that you know they're they're all good
they're all good skaters in their own
ways and uh
it's so fun I mean I I I didn't of
course they're surrounded by it their
whole life especially Riley because when
he was young I I didn't really have the
means to have child care whatever so I
just said take him with me on tourism
and whatnot so he was always around it
so he got good at it by default but at
some point started to shy away from him
because he felt the pressure and My
Shadow and it was like I don't this
isn't fun I don't people expect me to be
super good or I have to do this stuff
and so he went shied away from it but
then found
a bunch of his friends in high school
they love skating he's still good at us
so he that he found his crew and they've
all found their Crews
uh completely independent of me and so
when we go on vacation
for instance we we were last year we
were in uh or two years ago we were on
the big on Hawaii they want to go to Ski
parks
I don't want to go to the skate parks
I'm on vacation it's also a little harsh
stuff it's a great way to get hurt right
what's that over in Hawaii it's all
weather worn oh yeah and it's not even
my scene but but then so I go I'm I'm so
I'm their chauffeur and I'm their Filmer
I love it that's my vacation but but
because they all love it so much you
know what I mean and it just it's so
cool like I mean how could I ever ask
for more it's amazing
let's talk about Frank and Nancy a
little bit just because I have this kind
of odd connection to your family through
those uh it's really two or three day
interaction changed my life forever
meeting you was spectacular as a young
skateboarding kid but also just the idea
that someone would literally take me
into their home I mean they had every
reason to not trust me first of all I
was hanging out with Billy Waldman no
explanation needed the people who knew
Billy I hope he's doing well I haven't
heard anything about him but hope he's
doing well
um but we were wild but he basically
took me into your home he and Nancy took
me in
um you know fed us
um or fed me
um I had another friend with me
um and you know it I just have to
say as you're describing your family I
can only imagine what it must have been
like for Frank and Nancy to see you have
your kids did they get to
um live long enough to see uh that Riley
and your other kids were skateboarders
my dad met Riley uh but my dad passed
away when Riley was two
so he's the only one of my kids that
that he met yeah
um my older sibling uh had kids so he
met
two of his other grandkids besides Riley
um my mom got to see some of Riley's
success but uh she suffered from
Alzheimer's dementia and so things
slipped away but um
I I think that uh
my dad would not believe that
skateboarding is in the Olympics
to him that's that is the top of the
mountain because he was really into
other sport he loved Sports he loved the
Olympics he loves he loved watching
football he loved watching baseball he
loves when the Olympics were on he just
he loved the competition element and the
hype of it and and I think there was
part of him that felt like why isn't
skateboarding in this you know but he
knew that there were so many hurdles to
get through and so much more acceptance
that needed to happen and
I don't think he imagined would ever
happen
yeah he was a special guy I can still
hear his voice he was a very large guy
too I don't know if he I was just
smaller then I definitely was smaller oh
yeah no I mean he had like a big
presence and um and I know I've told you
this many times before this is actually
how we got reconnected I sent you a
direct message and said hey I met your
parents in fact they took me into your
home and I'm telling the truth and
you'll know I'm telling the truth
because they took me to dinner and they
ordered black coffee after dinner and
you know for years I would order black
coffee after dinner you know as a kid
you're just so impressionable these
really nice people took me in I was like
wow this is what a really healthy family
looks like I'm grateful to have loving
parents I always did but yeah I didn't
have the healthy family structure so for
me it was like oh my goodness these
people drink black coffee after this
must be what healthy families do so by
the way folks don't drink caffeine
within eight hours of going to sleep but
um but I still do that but well you it
doesn't seem to be holding you back
um individualized but
um yeah it's spectacular that this
lineage of you know Frank to you and and
I I mentioned and Nancy because it seems
like while she might not have been at
the contest and run around setting up
tables and doing all that like she
clearly was supportive as well oh oh she
was I did a lot of the events too I mean
they needed all hands on deck when it
started getting big and no one was
taking salaries you know that's the
thing is that people thought like oh
your dad's like cashing on he never took
up money for any of that
and he took so much you know what I
mean he just he just loved it it was for
you well
it was for me and it was also for the
Misfits that I surrounded myself with
and even though he was he was Brash and
he was like you know he was uh I don't
know what's the word
he was foreboding and intimidating and
whatever else he did it for all those
kids that were kind of lost like you I
mean really like he he loved that it
brought them together that he gave them
a sense of self it gave them a sense of
purpose he saw that because he he was
that he he really had a rough childhood
and he did everything he could through
his adult life to make up for it with
his own kids and with the kids that they
surrounded themselves with so that's
that's what he loved about it of course
he loved seeing me Thrive too but he
loved that he created the safe space and
this this sense of community and so my
mom my mom was that was her thing was
getting people together
gatherings
you know oh we should all get together
like
even even my siblings and I as much as
we want to emulate our parents we don't
do it as much that as they did and we
regret that
well there's still time no we I mean we
do but yeah um It's Tricky we're all
different areas sure yeah the the person
that comes to mind when I think about
your dad I'm forgetting the movie but
there's this one Clint Eastwood movie
where he lives in a neighborhood where I
think it's a bunch of young Hmong oh is
that gangsters El Camino El Camino yeah
and I just remember like there's that
scene of like Clint coming out on his
porch and just standing really upright
yeah everything in his front his front
lawn is everything's super manicured and
just standing there like this immense
presence and that's how I remember Frank
Hawk yeah but he was a total softy
that's the thing that's that's the you
know there there was a it was it was all
a front
well he was certainly very precious like
you you know you you got you got to see
that side of him where it's just like oh
yeah come on we'll we'll take you out
you want to go see Tony's Place let's go
like that's not some hard ass
well there's a tail end of the story too
where he actually called my mom
and I think there may have been a
statement or two about hey this kid's 14
like he can't be in Linda Vista Boys
Club taking the bus back to Lancaster et
cetera et cetera may have been some
discussion like that but then they also
paid for me to go home oh yeah they flew
me home yeah so I think I owe you a
couple hundred bucks for a Southwest
flight or whatever Airline it was well
it's it's fun and I think important to
reminisce about these people because
um they aren't just your parents but
they've done so much and through you you
know I I really think that
um emotions and stories are really like
the equivalent of energy in humans you
know when people talk about energy
because that gets carried forward
um
speaking of which we share a common love
of some particular music are you
somebody who listens to music to sort of
um to inspire you to get amped up to go
skateboard it's music an important part
of your life yeah let's put it this way
I had I had a playlist for my 540 the
other day okay
fine tune to that trick and what would
get me motivated in the Hypes
to to do it uh you don't have to share
with us what's on the playlist unless
you choose to oh man but was it high
energy low energy high energy well and
and some meaningful songs like um New
Order ceremony and uh
see nice nails getting smaller because
that was a song we used in one of our
big skate tours and it was one of the
most high energy sections of the show
um
uh gosh they were so I I can't go
through all of them I forget
um
uh gang of four
uh wait what's going for it is uh I
forgot what is it
um oh I find that Essence rare
fires up so I had I had like 10 that
were just gonna if any of those played
it's I'm gonna make it and and I knew
that it was about an hour and a half
and that's as long as I'm gonna try it
before I'm too tired so you're listening
in the warehouse or you're listening in
the warehouse on random
and then uh the song that I made it to
was uh off of that Prodigy album fat of
the Lamb uh and it's called clamatize
it's instrumental I use it for a
birdhouse edit when 4-1-1 was the thing
well remember these little like video
newsletter type things yeah anyway so
when that song came on
I I was feeling it I made it
fantastic I love this because you know
the neuroscientist In Me Is immediately
gonna say you know we have this brain
that loves to take an information and
discard other information but paired
Association is so strong yeah and when
you couple that with some sense of
reward like the making of the variable
below coping as a as as early in life or
making the 540fs as a comeback to you
know the injury
after the injury it was almost like I
loved all that music but I was
indoctrinated by it through the skate
parks because that was the soundtrack to
This it was it was punk music it was Sex
Pistols and and 999 and black flag and
Devo and X
Buzzcocks and you know that that was
that's what I kept hearing and that's
what I associate with my best of times
it's in your nervous system yeah yeah
there's a few voices you know rancid and
Tim Armstrong and and the Operation Ivy
Operation Ivy sound system sound system
was on that playlist was on the 540
playlist all right you know Tim will be
so happy to hear that and Matt Freeman
the bass player and Jesse Michaels is
now playing again with Tim the lead
singer of Operation Ivy yeah with their
new um their new gig what's it called
they had a name and then they they uh
they changed it oh okay initially it was
uh well I don't want to say because they
changed it for a reason but we know I
know they're making new music yeah which
is amazing operation Hive is incredible
my yearbook photo for I think two years
running was the cover of Operation Ivy
because I didn't show up for the
yearbook photo speaking of which did you
show up for yearbook photos or did you
graduate high school I graduated high
school but I didn't go to any of the
events
prom or any of the auxiliary I didn't
know I mean I was I was an outcast like
I was not
even though I had success in skating
skating wasn't cool and I was not homies
with anyone at school except for two
other skaters
and we felt very ostracized
so nah yeah I did show up for the
graduation because because my mom and
dad wanted to see it yeah likewise I
graduated but I could tell you more
about the curbs in the parking lot of my
high school than I could about anything
that happened in the class man I broke
so many sprinkler heads because the
sprinkler heads were right next to the
curb and there was a double-sided curb
and so if you board slide because I'd go
there early and board slide and then I'd
just like lean too far in and break the
sprinkler head and never got caught what
high school uh well I went to a couple I
went to Sarah High School originally
um then I went to San Diego High School
which is in North County and then I
ended up at Torrey Pines I got so
bullied at San Diego that I requested to
be transferred
because I I couldn't go I couldn't
survive there as a skater
I would have to hide my skateboard in
the bushes before class and then go find
it after school so that people wouldn't
Target me
the 80s were rough it was like it was
like a John Hughes film well for sure it
was jocks versus nerds and then skaters
were like
not even considered in that realm
because they're just gonna get they're
going to get hammered
because there were so few of us
well things have changed and not only
have things have changed such that
skateboarding is far more popular and
respected and
you know at least one mark of that is in
the Olympics although there are other
marks of respect certainly
but a huge Evolution that I've observed
is when I was
skateboarding as a 14 year old and you
know into my uh close to my 20s and then
took some time off
for sure
um hardly any girls hardly any women
there were a few like carabeth Burnside
they got
teased ridiculed it was hard on them
super hard yeah super hard now largely
through Instagram
um but some other channels as well you
can see this young girl Rhys onvert
skateboarding better than a lot of grown
men who have been skateboarding for
decades I mean um and then there are a
number of other ones in the um in Street
skateboarding
um and also taking really hard slams
like you know so this this is a complete
revision of the recent history of
skateboarding thoughts on that and um on
Reese and there are a few others was it
is it um Lizzy who uh took a really bad
fall that was filmed right there broke
the
um Knack offer femur yeah yeah these are
tough ladies yeah yeah I'm doing it and
for coming back Lizzy Lizzy did the loop
she did the full 360 Loop first woman to
ever do it
so what do you think changed like that
that paved the way is it just you know a
critical mass of uh females doing it is
it that
um you know Sky Brown you know for sure
for sure there were there were the
Pioneers people like care about the
Burnside
um and uh uh there's so many others um
Patty Hoffman was one of the one of the
first verse skaters to who were they
planted the seed and and then there were
other women that took inspiration like
oh girls can do this
even though they're largely outnumbered
and they get hassled for sure and then
through the street era
um people like Alyssa Steamer who who
paid the way for legit Street skating
um but then
through the years it started to become
more common
more accepted which is dumb to say
because it's just always been it should
have always been accepted but the thing
that that really tipped the scale was
when everything was leading up to the
Olympics
there had to be equal divisions in equal
disciplines
for men and women
and suddenly there was no question of
should we have a should we have a
women's event like no we have to have a
management because that's how we that's
the road to qualifying for this the
Olympic stage
and Vance Park series to their credit
they were holding events simultaneously
not that we're Olympic qualifiers but
just their own and they said these
events are equal across the board equal
prize money equal attention I mean it
was just like that that was just a
matter of fact and that shifted a lot
it really did now if you go to a
skatepark
you see plenty of them there yeah it's
awesome like literal women like moms you
know there's there are
older women that are learning how to
skate it's awesome
not that it matters so much but does
anyone claim to be the first female do
540 on vert is that sort of a known that
would be Lindsay Adams
fantastic
um and she did that I'll tell you how
she did that
she was trying it
um so she's trying she's trying to make
twists uh she's married to Travis
Pastrana it's like the you know
it's like the the Elite action sports
couple
um and she was trying them she was she
was getting pretty close and then we did
a big exhibition in Paris at the uh
Grand Palais on behalf of quicksilver it
was a huge event
um they put a half pipe up and we did
this giant show
there were thousands of people there and
it was very much
um
unspoken but expected that I was going
to do 900 at this event
um I think it was I want to say it was
2010 Maybe
and uh or no like 2009
and
and the organizers were kind of like
okay so we're gonna do this and then you
know at some point
you do a 900 and I was like I I can't
guarantee that ever like every time I've
ever made it it's been pretty
spontaneous I've you know I've set out
to do it and not I've come up short I
can't guarantee it I'll try I'll try
and they they're like yeah yeah okay and
so I knew the whole time when they were
skating I was like okay everyone's
expecting this so I kind of went through
the motions of of uh
doing my exhibition tricks you know
playing the hits and then started trying
900s and at the same time Lindsay
started trying 540s because she was
feeling that energy
and so it was this sort of not battle
but definitely we were we were trading
hits it was like all right here goes
Tony no he missed it and here goes
Lindsay oh she missed it and then
I uh
she almost made one like was riding down
you know and and then fell at the flat
bottom
it was like oh and then I made 900 and
it was kind of the show stopper
because like that's what they expected
and everyone's going crazy and whatever
people are coming down off the ramp knee
sliding down and we're saying goodbye to
the crowd and I look up and Lindsay puts
her tail out
there's still people standing on the
ramp
and she puts her tail out and I was like
I think Lindsay wants to try it again
here we go I'm on the mic now
she made it
love it she stole the show
like without question it was huge you
can look it up on on YouTube like it's
there Lindsay Adams first first 540. it
was awesome and then she made it and we
all grabbed her and put her on her
shoulders
that is awesome it was pretty cool that
was awesome because these things are
like the four minute mile
as a barrier then people break that
barrier and then other people break that
barrier it's I mean I I watched enough
of skateboarding recent years see you
know like the sky Brown thing she's
phenomenal and I actually saw her family
out to dinner
here in Los Angeles and um with her
brother and her folks are really
gracious really nice and there again you
know parents going to the skate park
after all she's couldn't drive herself I
think she's at that time she was
probably like nine you know probably one
of the biggest shifts too is that
parents encourage their kids to skate
now could you imagine that when we were
young
never no there were so many factors
telling us not to it's just made us want
to do it more sure but yeah now now kids
are like parents are pushing them into
it get out there learn tricks it's like
wait that's not what we're supposed to
be doing but
it's cool that that I think it I think
with the the really cool factor of all
that is there are definitely people our
age
I'm grouping you into my age category
47. all right yeah plus enough
um but but that have kids and and
skateboarding was such a special time in
our life and then they're rediscovering
it through their kids and they're
skating together and I think that's just
so amazing
that someone of our age would be like
you know what I used to do that you're
into that like let's go and then you
could show your kid how to do a sweeper
I could probably do that I don't have
kids yet but when I do I'll show I
intend on being healthy enough and yeah
to do a sweeper people can look up
sweeper we don't have to explain it for
him but a little laid back grind or a
sweeper yep oh yeah because they won't
they wouldn't think to do it no and they
are doing all these difficult flip
tricks and that's not my it's not my
scene oh yeah what's your go-to on a
game escape if you're gonna really like
take out the younger generation
um I can do Impossibles pretty uh
pretty regularly on transition
consistently I knew I'm flat so this is
where basically you scrape the back of
the it's an ollie really but it wraps
around the back of it over your foot
yeah um that's kind of my my sneak
attack on game's Escape does Rodney
Mullen get credit for that trick still
oh yes that's yeah it's a Rodney are you
still in touch with Rodney absolutely
yeah yeah he's somebody that um
certainly deserves deserves mention in
the pioneering of tricks I think if he's
the Godfather of modern skateboarding I
think of Rodney you and Mark Gonzalez
gons as like the the guys that I'm
honored drove the
um the progression in different
partially overlapping directions that
set the template for us I learned
fingertips because of Rodney like the
first trick you saw me do I learned that
because I saw Rodney do it on the ground
and I thought well
I can't do it on the ground but I have
plenty of time in the air to do it
it's awesome it's awesome that Stacy put
you guys together we we mentioned Bones
Brigade but we didn't really talk about
the architecture of it from the
perspective of skateboard progression
but it was
um kind of like any good band it seemed
like there was really good chemistry
yeah um interpersonally but also
um that there was each person had
something unique you skated the way you
did Mike skate the way he did Stevie the
way he did and you know Rodney and you
know and we respected each other but we
also fed off each other Tommy Guerrero
yep right because growing up in the Bay
Area like yeah in fact Tommy's getting
the hills of San Francisco in those
videos makes it look easy yeah but those
Hills are are rough they're dangerous
and they have real life obstacles like
moving buses you'll notice he wasn't
stopping his top signs so that's
fantastic uh we could reminisce about
all these angles but the the point being
that um
spending time with people who do similar
things or the same thing but do it
differently is one of the best ways to
progress that's why I routinely fly to
Texas and hang out with Peter attia
another podcaster Lex Friedman just
because they do things differently than
I do
um where do you draw sort of peripheral
inspiration from now like I know you I
see Jimmy Wilkins at your ramp quite a
lot the Phenom Jimmy Wilkins it's kind
of eerie how good that kid is
um who else are you spending time with
besides Rhys and one of the reasons I
asked this is that skateboarding is
unique among many sports in that
a given session a gathering uh to
skateboard will include an enormous
five-year-old man and 10 year old girls
exactly yes which is which is incredible
you don't think about soccer you know a
serious game of soccer between
professional soccer but also it's not
even that we're skating together is that
we are
communicating and influencing each other
I mean that is like
the last conversation I have with Rhys
was she's talking about like are you
gonna try to do 540 stand I go yeah I'm
kind of working on it she goes well I
think because she saw me try one she
goes I think you need to pull out a
little more and she was right
and she's how old again she's 10.
and I and I didn't even consider that
because I'm just back in my mode and I'm
not taking into consideration that I
don't have the snap that I had before I
got hurt and she was I mean that was one
key to me making it
and you know did that that's but it but
to me that's just
that's representative skateboarding and
the inclusivity of it and the diversity
of it where it's me I'm 55 there's 30
year old uh
Pros that are at the top of the game
there are 17 year old
up and comers men women 10 year old girl
that is doing tricks that we've never
even thought of
or want to do
and it's all part of the
the whole mix that's really beautiful I
want to ask you about
memorabilia
not a topic that I think about much but
I think in a prior conversation of ours
you mentioned something about this so
you know there are skateboard collectors
there are people that collect stickers
skateboards there's a whole market and
world for this and um in addition to
people wanting selfies with you when
they see you I imagine
um there's a long history and continued
tradition of people taking a pen putting
your hand and saying can you sign this
right because um you are in this uh very
uh small but very
um clearly esteemed group of people
where your signature increases the value
of things so how does that work uh and
how does that feel like if a
skateboarder who you know there are the
telltale signs of who is and who isn't
right
um
um if they walk up to you and they're
like hey will you sign this do you feel
good about signing it or is that
something that you refrain from and if
somebody's just merely a collector a
Trader and they're trying to
um build their portfolio so to speak
um you can probably also sense that so
I'm not trying to put you uh in the hot
seat here
um well to answer your question
through the years
I was always open to that and and I'm
happy to
um especially when people are skaters or
Escape fans and whatnot in the last
three years there has been this new
element of resellers of people that just
go buy signature stuff they have nothing
to do with skating they don't care about
skateboarding at all they just want to
get my signature on an item and sell it
and they usually do it on eBay or
through their own channels
um that's fine at some point like a few
years ago I respected the hustle these
guys are they knew that I was going to
be at this event okay they're outside
waiting they've been waiting for hours
I'll sign a couple things
but in recent months even they have
figured out how to get my flight info
like some hacked into my my actual
Airline accounts
some have sources at certain airports
that get the Manifest and they sell the
information I found all this out because
I've actually held a couple of them
accountable because I said look I'm not
going to sign this until you tell me how
you knew I was going to be here I have
no business here I'm here to visit
family no one knows I'm coming here oh
well we saw a friend said they saw you
at the uh Detroit airport like no they
didn't
they wouldn't know where I'm going to
anyway like why I saw it on Twitter you
didn't see it on Twitter I'm on Twitter
tell me the truth
there's a guy from TMZ that gets flight
info and he sells it to us
okay thank you but that has increased to
a point where it's not it's not
sustainable I can't I can't please
everyone the last time I flew out of
Chicago there were about 15 people one
guy had a shopping cart full of
skateboards
and they all they all bum rushed me at
security before I went through security
thinking that I'm going to sign stuff
I'm like you guys I can't I can't do
that I might miss my flight and I can't
delineate who like I I I'm sorry you
guys have like sabotaged yourselves I
don't know what to say and then I went
through security
and there were four D's waiting at the
gate they had bought tickets airline
tickets so that it could be past
security that they airline tickets
they're not going to use
to chase this
wow so
I mean when people want My Autograph but
it's weird and it's intrusive and it's
kind of creepy
yeah just tell them that a
neuroscientist told you that you got to
get that slob air right and if you sign
too many autographs that uh
you're not going to get the tuck knee
you're not just not going to be do the
flat knee invert you're just not going
to get anyway it is it's just a really
weird new thing that is weird it has
popped up and
um other than that and and so the tricky
part is when there is a public thing or
a public exhibition or whatever to try
to figure out who is the true skate fans
and who aren't
um usually they're pretty identifiable
but it it just it has ruined the
experience for people who truly are the
grew up skating
uh well thanks for sharing that and um
we won't tell everyone what the telltale
signs are so that these people don't
exploit them the skateboarders the real
fans will know
um uh they won't have to worry about
whether or not they represent accurately
because you just will
um on the positive side something I've
been wanting to learn more about from
you is your philanthropic efforts
um I think
Kevin Rose
um who's in the tech sector was the
first to mention to me that you have you
guys have done some philanthropy
together
um and maybe you've done some with Jim
thibo as well the great Jim thibo yeah
uh well both both Jim and Kevin were
board members uh Jim is the current
board member of the skateboard project
but tell us about the skateboard project
um it's it's it's my non-profit and we
try to develop public skate parks in our
certain underserved areas but more so by
by supporting the community and giving
them the resources to do so so groups
that are trying to get skate parks in
the area we are the resource center for
them
um we'll give them advice we'll give
them funding we'll give them uh our
stamp of approval and that can go a long
way and uh to date we've helped to fund
over almost a thousand skate parks now
and seven or eight hundred of which are
open
um I mean it's my proudest word for sure
and and it's because
I never
I I never took for granted the fact that
I grew up near a skatepark and that was
my home away from home that was where I
found my sense of community my sense of
identity my my crew and so many kids
choose the skateboard but have no
support in doing so and so those skate
parks are a lifeline yeah I can attest
they they absolutely save lives there's
no question where can people find out
more about your foundation we can
provide a link but where dot org so
where does the funding for these Parks
actually come from
um it comes from donations from
supporters it comes from fundraisers
some corporate uh sometimes funding is
is funneled through us for specific
regions
um like the uh uh we have a built to
play project that's in Michigan and New
York and that's funded by the Ralph C
Wilson Junior Foundation
um so they they give us the funding and
then we have to
give it to that area but but it's easy
because there's plenty of projects and
now there's an abundance of skate parks
in those areas I love it thank you for
doing that for organizing around that
and I get to get more places to skate
[Laughter]
I'm curious what's in the immediate
Horizon right
um these days you probably have the
option to say yes to things and no to
things
um you know you have a family you have
your skateboard career
um
where do you place your priorities in
terms of how to carve up your day or
your week I mean what would you like to
make sure that you do
or as much of the hours of your waking
day for the next let's just say five
years because and if you want to extend
that out you can but um well I I want to
be available to my kids first and
foremost
um and we still have one at home for the
next four years so uh I will make sure
that I'm available to her and
in terms of career I never had great
aspirations like I never thought okay
these are this is what I want to
accomplish it was always just very
more you know trick specific oriented so
it's always like I want to try this and
this and this I would like to continue
skating I don't know if I'll be able to
skate at the level I'm skating right now
in five years but I know that I'll still
be on the ramp I may not be doing it in
public
um
trying to advocate for public skate
parks doing more with the foundation
um and whatever I think I think the way
I prioritize My Time is what will
resonate the furthest and have the best
impact on skateboarding in general I do
feel
that I've come to a point where yes I'm
some
um unofficial ambassador to
skateboarding and I want to represent it
well I want I want to
be fair in that skateboarding has all
kinds of different things it's not just
X Games or Olympics or or whatnot it
represents
[Music]
um
a true culture
and
I want to
project that as much as I can and make
sure that people understand that that's
also positive
um and
I mean it really everything that I'm
doing now is just kind of fun
okay it's for the I would say in the
last five to ten years is the first time
I've truly enjoyed what skateboarding
has provided me in terms of opportunity
and what it brings to me and and what it
means to my family like I have a much
better appreciation understanding for it
and these days it's just like
everything's kind of just gravy it's
just so fun I can't believe I can still
do it for a living it's crazy I'm 55
years old
and I truly ride my skateboard as a
career like that's nuts and I won't have
it in any other way
well it certainly is earned and um I
just want to say thank you for a number
of things first of all
um
thank you for going to the skate park
thank you for picking this trajectory
thank you for inspiring me and so many
other young people and old people older
people over so many decades now both
with what you did on a skateboard and
off the skateboard and including your
resilience and determination to push and
continue to progress to the point where
you were badly injured and then to push
through that come back at least match
what you did previously and I I would
wager that you will exceed your prior
skill level going forward so I want to
thank you for your resilience I know it
comes from an intrinsic Drive
um Your Love of skateboarding it just
absolutely comes through I share in some
of that um of course having grown up in
it but not nearly as much as you but
also just your willingness to stretch
out into these different areas like the
video game thing or talk about X Games
um uh the Olympics because that did
allow for a lot of growth and lateral
movement of skateboarding
and at the same time just as you said to
bring it right back to the fact that
skateboarding isn't one thing it is not
like other sports it's its own Sport and
it's its own lifestyle it's its own
thing
um and we do consider you the Ambassador
for skateboarding and appreciate it um I
speak for many people and I say that uh
we're very grateful that you are because
you bring that that shrewdness and that
Prudence to it but also that get after
it punk rock Spirit and the goodness
that your parents you know instilled in
you clearly comes through everything
from the philanthropy and onward so I
can't say enough positive things and or
express enough gratitude for your what
you've gone in for your time here your
legacy in skateboarding but also just in
the Game of Life is clearly cemented so
thank you oh thank you well hey I and I
appreciate that the ethos of
skateboarding shines through on your
show and just your crew here it's
clearly a lot of them come from the
skateboard world so you're you're still
supporting it whether you know it or not
thanks so much and uh hopefully you'll
come back and we'll do it again all
right
sounds good
thank you for joining me for today's
discussion with Tony Hawk if you're
learning from and or enjoying this
podcast please subscribe to our YouTube
channel that's a terrific zero cost way
to support us in addition please
subscribe to the podcast on Spotify and
apple and on both Spotify and apple you
can leave us up to a five star review if
you have questions for me or comments
about the podcast or guests that you'd
like me to consider hosting on the
huberman Lab podcast please put those in
the comment section on YouTube I do read
all the comments please also check out
the sponsors mentioned at the beginning
and throughout today's episode that's
the best way to support this podcast not
on today's podcast but on many previous
episodes of The huberman Lab podcast we
discuss supplements while supplements
aren't necessary for everybody many
people derive tremendous benefit from
them for things like improving sleep
hormone support and focus the huberman
Lab podcast has partnered with momentous
supplements if you'd like to access the
supplements discussed on the huberman
Lab podcast you can go to live momentous
spelled ous so it's livemomentis.com
huberman you can also receive 20 percent
off again that's live momentous spelled
ous.com slash huberman if you haven't
already subscribed to our neural network
newsletter our neural network newsletter
is a completely zero cost monthly
newsletter that includes summaries of
podcast episodes as well as protocols
that is short PDFs describing for
instance tools to improve sleep tools to
improve neuroplasticity we talk about
deliberate cold exposure Fitness various
aspects of mental health again all
completely zero cost and to sign up you
simply go to hubermanlab.com go over to
the menu in the corner scroll down to
newsletter and provide your email we do
not share your email with anybody if
you're not already following me on
social media I am hubermanlab on all
platforms so that's Instagram Twitter
threads LinkedIn and Facebook and at all
of those places I talk about science and
science related tools some of which
overlaps with the content of the
huberman Lab podcast but much of which
is distinct from the content of the
huberman Lab podcast again it's a
huberman lab on all social media
platforms thank you for joining me for
today's disc with Tony Hawk and last but
certainly not least thank you for your
interest in science
[Music]